All right, so let's start sort of
climbing up the visual system,
starting at the bottom,
which of course is the eye.
And here is a sort of
a schematic picture of the eye.
And you know, lights coming in this way,
and there are a variety of structures.
Let's see, a couple that we'll,
we will mention.
So you have this lens here.
Lens changes, what's in focus.
And by the way, you have what might
be thought of a spherical retina.
And so, the, in some sense,
spherical retinas are a lot easier
to deal with planar retinas.
We make, we put planar retinas
in cameras, things like that,
spherical means all the rays are sort
of the same, which is kind of nice.
The other thing to notice
on these lenses is,
that they're attached by
these fibers right here.
And those fibers pull on the lens,
and they cause the lens to,
to deform, which changes the focus,
and that's how you focus near and far.
Well that's how you focus near and far.
The way I focus near and
far is I put on reading classes.
Why is that?
Because I'm old.
Well, I'm not that old, but what
happens is my eyeballs think I'm old.
In fact, sometime, right around my
40th birthday, I looked at my watch,
and I was trying to wonder how my watch
knew it was my 40th birthday because it
decided to go out of focus,
just that day.
But what happens is,
the ability of your,
of those fibers to deform that lens,
that lens, it hardens up a bit.
And, and you lose the ability
to deform the lens as much and
you can't do near focus.
And that's why you see
those of us with less hair
carrying around reading glasses.
So, the lens focuses
the light coming in,
goes through this center
called the pupil.
You have a certain amount of
adjustment of the size of the pupil to,
in terms of the amount of
light that's in there.
We'll, we'll talk about
the dynamic range in a minute.
And then what happens is
the light passes through a,
a clear liquid,
which keeps the eye in its shape, and
it projects onto this back
area called the retina.
Okay.
And, one of the things you'll also
notice in here is that there's this
optic nerve, there's also a bunch
of blood vessels that come in and
feed the retina.
And we'll talk, in a little bit,
about how come it is that it comes
all the way up through here, so
that it actually sees the, the middle
here that is, it's not just in the back.
But when you look in there, what you
would see is a funny little area.
It's, referred to as the optic disc or
the blind spot.
And in fact, if you've ever
been to an ophthalmologist and
he looks in your eye,
what he sees is something like this.
All right?
That's assuming everything's healthy.
So there are all these blood vessels
that are nurturing the, the retina, and
then there's this area in the middle
where the blood vessels and, and
nerves are coming together and
that's your blind spot.